hello and welcome to this video playing
troll bets no name ok so in English
opening caption should promote that ok
so d5 what do I do here I think I go d
three
[Music]
of course you can also take but I think
I can be three years position it's good
but I'm absolutely not sure absolutely I
forgotten what I hope the head
recommended there was it taking on d5 I
already have to look that up there was
one very similar position where d3 is
correct I will see I mean this cannot be
terribly bad at least that would be
quite surprising c5 here okay
isn't it dangerous for black that looks
dangerous to me I'm threatening 23 okay
so well a six you probably has to go 86
I just wonder if I have something great
now probably not but be going back it's
not unreasonable check so here can I do
something there I mean I've got the I'm
slightly better developed like a bishop
at 446 or something probably not do you
wanna shoot you for why do I just stop
anything then let let me stop queenside
plane okay couldn't play be 60 B 5
anyway I was probably not necessary we
actually played h3 actually preventing
any bishop geforce yeah i know he plays
it something that i probably should have
prevented
you
Knight b6 get rid of this option in 95
he wants to play okay but let's say h3
Bishop h5 I probably should play Bishop
f1 anyway it's an interesting position
95 he basically has to play that move 94
is probably a bit too much of it if it
arrives or he has a tactical solutions
amount that i don't see otherwise 95 is
pretty much force okay and then what do
i do 95 maybe I'm just playing a for
this one okay it's a very direct
solution so I'm taking be 394 looks like
the normal way to play let's do it maybe
should be five now I shoulda thought
about that for a moment but okay it
cannot be absolutely bad that's you wow
I did not think that he can allow this
kind of transformation maybe he can but
I did not calculate variations maybe
he's doing it supported by technical
ideas specialty three or something or
this one
[Music]
and that's a negative position it's got
an active position here pieces I active
the structures is really really bad but
always pieces are very active and that
is often just far more important than
any structural considerations I don't
know I might be fine yeah but it looks a
little bit a little bit off my my piece
placement here please so this trade it
and nice again it's all active so that i
can take a six Bishop d3 Bishop d3 is
quite annoying so Eddie let's do that it
also supports the deep one now a porn is
hanging hanging for real so if i take it
is going to take on c4 I can play Bishop
f1 just covering everything
maybe that's too lame I don't know Quinn
a five-night a4 would be good since
against a bit on the lame side and she
can't cover with 97 94 95 or stuff like
that iam this is possible 94 95 mm time
won't do anything really doesn't do
anything I queen 85 was probably rather
stupid to smooth this is probably even
worse how am i doing that I don't see a
good move him nothing really good
30 seconds mmm yeah kind of expected
that but I didn't really see what to do
my queen s basically no squares 2095 is
coming I should could have could have
done that already Queen a4 may be very
shaky situation you can play 95 the
whole time and somehow it doesn't do it
I completely miss play dead from a very
good position white foreheads on time I
was bad I think after I think they're I
think white should be better this is
really I cannot believe that I'm not
able to extinguish this piece activity
that he has maybe it is okay so I mean
exactly after after here I mean him but
it should be really better yeah I've
misplaced my pieces down the screen 85
business was probably bad but how do i
play I should probably play on the e
failure so I mean this this is probably
not so bad I'm fairly happy up to here
and now i have to prove that improve i
mean this this plan is probably leading
absolutely nowhere but how do i do it
a computer place might be five which is
I which I don't understand I mean okay
it's a technical thing nd6 but I'm not
quite understanding as what this
actually threatened maybe Justin I to c7
I mean the line that the computer gives
us a joke yeah like yeah black can
basically resign if this is the best
line white is basically winning then but
then don't see why this is the best line
because the n97 then I'm just taking a
60 Queen III III okay yeah I mean okay
I've broken that blockade and now now I
can go to e3 it is difficult than to
hold a six and c5 so I had to do this
harm okay that wasn't very intuitive to
me of course as I saw that I can play
this but i didn't i didn't really
understand that d 6 is strong and then
this this was really bad okay 95 now and
97 wins but okay I was completely on the
wrong track here I mean I took a long
time for night a forward
[Music]
I simply didn't consider that this is
this is a decent move at all this is
winning I can just take everything oh my
god and that was really simple I just
didn't think about my own it's not a
Miss evaluation in a way I just had it I
mean I just did not think of it and here
I'm kind of falling apart and he can
play 95 the whole time which is didn't
do for some reason I never a.m. this is
just a bad position my coding have no
coordination somehow i never went 95 but
i had known this is just a bad position
9 9 9 a-4 is terrible I kind of saw that
after 97 that's leading nowhere but I
didn't see another move and I have to do
not be five it's just like that you play
it you're winning you play something
else your words it's just one of those
situations okay thanks for watching guys